dear Divya I miss you
I'm sorry I haven't contacted you after
what happened I'm not scared it's more
than fear that's the second element that
play I keep trying to reel you back but
something bigger than fear keeps cutting
my strengths but I've decided to stand
up to fear like a steel cable remember
when I took you to the fair
that red balloon
more beautiful of Sun and I just had to
put the needle to the record
I couldn't hold on to that
so we watched it float away together
drifted in the autumn air to us just a
speck
and then it's nothing at all I can't
remember being that happy
I'd like to think it's still up there
somewhere eventually it will run out of
hot air and sink back down into my arms
but I know that will take time I cannot
ask you to forgive me for what I did but
I'd like to ask you to move on I wish
you could know how hard I've been trying
to try again I've got the hair back into
my lungs and I still can't breathe
without you I hope this letter finds you
better than I've been the last few
months and I'd really like to hear your
song again sometimes sincerely Feder
better can't you take a damn hint there
is nothing you can do to make me love
you again so just saw I guess nobody
bothered to relay you the message again
they're so disgusting why should they I
left the world of the living
Oh
after what you did to me I couldn't go
on living in the same world as humans
thought of breathing the same air is you
is nauseating better you single-handedly
ruined the Doyle life for me
what pathetic efforts just sickened me
where I am now is infinitely better
I have suitors who will go at any length
to please me they will do my bidding if
you don't leave me alone they will haunt
you every moment of every day so there
you go
I have given you fair warning the most I
can do is bid you a cold farewell Devia